We are here with the amazing women from,
"And just like that", Nicole, Karen, Sarita.
Okay. I'm wondering if I can, as a last round,
play a little game with you
and do a round robin rapid style.
Will you do that with me?
Yeah, yeah
All right. It's time for the final five.
(upbeat drum music)
(crowd claps)
Okay. I'm so excited. Okay.
Nicole, what never fails to make you laugh?
My kids and my dogs, yeah.
Karen.
My daughter and my kids.
My daughter is a clown. She's hilarious, hilarious.
My daughter. Dry humor.
Catherine Tate, British comedian.
[Nicole And Karen] Oh. Mmm.
What is your favorite chore, Nicole?
Ooh.
Laundry.
Me too.
Yeah. I like ironing too.
It's very old fashioned, I know.
Gosh, I need for you to come over to my house.
(Nicole chuckles)
I can shine shoes too.
Ooh.
I went to NYU with a shoe shine kit.
At my house, later.
Karen, favorite chore?
I like to mop floors.
Mmm.
I really do not like a dirty floor.
I like to sweep and then I like to...
I have stayed up until two in the morning,
mopping all the floors in my house.
Cleanliness is next to godliness. Sarita.
Washing dishes is the only thing I can do and I do it.
(all laugh)
Your house is better off for it.
I feel like my dishes are constantly piled up in the sink.
Okay. Nicole, worst date you ever had.
Ah.
Ooh, it's been so long.
(all laugh)
Pass. (buzzer sound) I don't know. I can't think of one.
Back in another day. Karen.
The worst date I ever had was I went out with a guy
who was a little bit older than me.
By little, I mean a lot, and at the end of the date
he stood up and he had this little New York Times
in his hand and he hit his knee
and was like, "Well, that's that",
And I was like, "Oh no. (all laugh)
Grandpa, we can't go out anymore".
(all laugh)
It was like, (slaps knee)
that was a good date.
And I was like, "No, it wasn't".
Oh my gosh.
(indistinct)
Not gonna be on a date with you no more.
Sarita.
I shouldn't say.
So I went on a date with a kind of famous musician
and we went to a club and we were in the VIP section
and he didn't talk to me all night.
Worst date ever.
Oh.
He apologized much later.
Oh, good. I love...
Listen, women love closure.
Oh my God.
We live for it.
Yes.
Men, it's true.
Okay. Favorite, currently bingeing or watching a show.
I'm caught up on "The Morning Show", ladies and gentlemen.
Oh, oh, oh.
And yeah, and Harlem.
Harlem.
Yes. I binge watch Harlem.
Okay. I'm gonna check that out.
Yes.
I put out watch lists.
I like to watch everything, expand my horizons.
You're going to die. It's so good.
Okay. Okay, I'm watching it. Thank you. Karen.
I love Meghan Good. Queer Eye. (crowd claps)
The best.
Oh.
It's such a good show, isn't it?
This season in Austin.
It's a feel good, in Austin.
So good.
Feel good.
So lately, I've been Googling
best independent Indian movies,
catching up on my country.
And two, I'm rewatching, "May I destroy you?"
It's the best.
[Nicole And Karen] Ooh.
It's the best, if anyone hasn't seen,
"May I destroy you?" please watch it immediately.
Yes.
Okay.
Are you a Carrie, Miranda, a Charlotte or a Samantha?
I'm all of them.
That's the point.
(all laugh)
Well, Karen.
I gotta say I'm a Nya (indistinct)
Ooh.
What an answer.
Yes.
No, and you know what, I am. I am.
I've got great art.
I have a Mercedes and...
And I mean, J, they're good in bed.
I'm good in bed. What can I say?
(all laugh and cheer)
I love that.
I love the Rambo.
Rambo, right.
Gosh. Sarita.
I'm a Carrie.
Oh. oh.
Yeah, I get that.
Well, you guys have picked up this mantle
and torch and you have just run with it
and I just appreciate you and celebrate you so much.
Nicole Ari Parker, Karen Pittman and Sarita Choudhury.
(crowd claps)
Thank you so much.
"And just like that" is available on HBO Max
and thank you for putting it out into the world.
(upbeat theme music)